comédienne dramaturge j'écrivaine elle
fait partie du paysage culturel du
Québec depuis 40 ans parmi ces
réalisations Marie Laberge peut être
fier d'avoir contribué à propager le
goût de la lecture chez un grand nombre
de familles québécoises ça trilogie le
goût du bonheur ce est encore parmi les
livres francophones les plus vendus
pétillante vivante pourquoi se sent-elle
si à l'aise dans le drame son prochain
roman d'ailleurs sera publié dans
quelques mois cet automne je l'ai
rencontré il y a quelques jours à la
Grande Bibliothèque
Marie Laberge bonjour à la Grande
Bibliothèque à Montréal est-ce que vous
êtes vous dans la vie entouré de livres
êtes-vous quel genre de lectrice
êtes-vous une vraie c'est-à-dire pas
quelqu'un qui essaie de voir ce qu'elle
a pas faite mais je m'en vais dans un
univers qui me plaît qui m'emporte et
j'espère qu'il me fait oublier tout le
reste est-ce que vous lisez beaucoup oui
mais pas assez pas autant que je
voudrais parce que je trouve que c'est
difficile de tous les soirs c'est sûr
avant de dormir il faut que je les ai
toujours un livre à côté de moi mais des
fois j'attends d'avoir un rhume pour
pouvoir lire tout un livre en paix sinon
je fais tu n'as pas le droit faut que tu
travailles et puis tout ça je suis pas
une lectrice je suis un peu maniaque
j'aime ça rentrer dans un livre puis
pense au travers je me suis allé vite
c'est toujours ce que je souhaite du
lecteur à moi qui est tellement envie
que je veux pas tellement capable de le
poser mais bon mon rapport à la
littérature c'est un rapport d'histoire
de raconter quelque chose choses me
faire raconter quelque chose avant tout
c'était ce qui m'intéressait de
m'importer puis c'est demeurer je sais
pas quelqu’un qui écrit pour pour donner
mettons des réponses
je suis quelqu'un pour raconter des
choses pour raconter des êtres humains
plus on est proche de l'être humain plus
plus j'aime ça et plus on est proche du
tourment on avait l'impression plus vous
aimez ça il y a cette phrase qu'on
retrouve partout quand on commence à
lire sur vous Marie Laberge je pensais
tellement de partait écrit des choses si
tristes oui ma mère c'est exactement ça
c'est ma main tu es tellement portée
mais pourquoi vous écrivez des choses
avec des personnages j'ai sentiments que
la vie c'est pas juste un pointé
justement mais que pour rire il faut
savoir ce qu'on sent il faut il faut
ressentir tout ce qu'on sent incluant le
sens du trajet de l'existence le sens de
la gravité de la vie puis en même temps
le sens de la
de même du temps qui passe j'étais toute
petite et je savais que le temps passé à
5 ans je courais puis je me dis cours
plus vite parce que l'autre est à peu
près à ton top quand tu veux être
vieille tu pourras pas c'est bizarre
d'être si de penser déjà que les choses
vont s'altérer vont se détruire vont se
défaire peut-être que c'est pour ça que
j'écris des choses qui sont quelquefois
tristes mais qui sont toujours liées à
mon envie de vivre mon désir de vivre et
mon élan pour vivre alors ce talent de
conteuse là vous l'avez vu dès vos
premiers romans que vous aviez quelque
chose que vous aviez une recette mais
vous saviez comment raconter quand
j'étais petite petite j'avais juste une
lectrice puis c'était ma soirée ma soeur
Francine et cette lectrice là m'a donné
le plus grand cadeau qu'un écrivain peut
avoir moi je racontais des histoires
plein les maisons à lire enfin que je
racontais l'histoire Alizée a fait un
autre
mais je pense que c'est de l'or qui est
venu mon talent de conteuse ou peut-être
je sais pas mais c'était toujours des
histoires inventées mais dans ma tête si
j'attends quelqu'un pendant un quart
d'heure il est mort de mille façons
avant d'arriver c'est bintana d'avoir
beaucoup d'imagination
oui Marie Laberge beaucoup d'imagination
une des plus célèbres conteuses du
Québec en fait
pour une fois
j'ai envoyé du bois aujourd'hui pomme de
rester 20 pièces de théâtre vous avez
pas envie d'écrire des romans par
exemple
j'ai très envie d'écrire des romans
d'écrire mais j'ai très peur
avec ce penchant pour les grands
tourments de la vie perdre un enfant un
amour la déchirure l'absence la
séparation et la vie qui continue malgré
tout dans contre coup son dernier roman
paru en 2021 un jumeau mal dans sa peau
incapable de vivre une séparation avec
son frère se venge et tu trois femmes
dans une boutique de vêtements le roman
explore le choc vécu par l'entourage
pour ceux qui restent pour reprendre le
titre d'un autre de ses romans ce thème
de la violence faite aux femmes par des
hommes faibles ou blessés étaient déjà
présent dans un de ses premiers romans
écrit il y a plus de 35 ans juillet un
opéra dramatique qu'il faut lire ou
relire est-ce que c'est parce que vous
regardez la société puis ça ça vous
révolte les féminicides il y en a il y
en a eu 14 je pense l'an dernier on en
parle beaucoup dans les bulletins de
nouvelles et vous transposez ça c'est
votre façon de de dire l'époque je
l'absorbe l'époque je l'absorbe comme
n'importe quel artiste absorbe l'époque
j'absorbe
l'inquiétude ambiante j'absorbe la
violence ambiante j'absorbe tout comme
j'ai toujours comme une éponge placée
dans le milieu d'une société je me je me
gorge de l'eau que cette société me
donne et quand j'écris je suis presse
sur l'éponge mais c'est sûr que je pense
que pas d'artistes qui est pas de
sensibilité je pense que si on n'a pas
ou si on est en défense de cette
sensibilité là ça marchera pas on se
rend pas capable d'être un grand
interprète on se rend pas capable de
faire une musique extraordinaire il faut
quelquefois accepter d'avoir mal si on
veut pouvoir créer mais ça veut pas dire
qu'il faut toujours créer dans
l'artiste maudit le sauce
verte pour vivre ou vous parler au jeûne
vous prenez 13 verbes et vous élaborez
bon c'est intéressant et vous parlez de
la création puis vous dites moi je suis
pas quelqu'un tourmenté c'est ce mythe
que l'artiste doit être à terre pour
créer des tragédies on peut créer des
tragédies sans vivre une vie mais c'est
sûr qu'on le ressent c'est à dire que
c'est pas moi qui saigne c'est ça mais
je sens la blessure des autres je la
sens profondément c'est sûr que on peut
pas se mettre à créer des des grandes
drames humains on peut pas créer un
tourment comme vous avez si bien dit
sans le ressentir
je suis pas tourmenter disons que ça
peut m'arriver d'avoir mes heures de
profonde angoisse ou d'anxiété mais je
suis pas anxieuse non c'est pas ça c'est
lié à ma conscience puis je dirais à ma
lucidité inclucide c'est important et
vous sentez la blessure des femmes parce
que dès vos premiers juillet en fait que
votre deuxième c'est le premier qui a
été publié le premier publié mais le
deuxième
énervé au début parce que le personnage
de l'homme
et tellement faible qu'il devient
violent et je me disais c'est vous
explorez les racines du mal de ces
hommes là qui sont pas bien qui sont
faibles et qui font donc du mal aux
femmes oui bien quelques femmes qui font
mal aux hommes aussi parce que je pense
que je comprends aussi la détresse des
mâles et des hommes je pense que je peux
comprendre ça il y en a des violences
qui sont muettes qui sont sans bruit
sans bleu sans rien et c'est ces
violences là qui m'intéressent aussi
les drames font parfois naître de
grandes choses c'est un peu ce que Marie
Laberge a raconté dans ses pièces ou ses
romans même chose dans sa vie parce que
nous avons l'intime conviction que
persister à l'intérieur du Canada
signifierait s'étioler et dénaturer
notre identité même le Québec est un
pays souverain
Jacques Parisot lui avait demandé de
participer à la rédaction du préambule
de la déclaration d'indépendance du
Québec à 22h20 heure de l'Est
Radio-Canada prévoit si la tendance du
vote se maintient que c'est l'option du
nom qui rapportera ce référendum le nom
l'emporte par la peau des dents et Marie
Laberge très déçu se dit qu'elle devrait
retourner à ses stylos pour faire ce
qu'elle fait de mieux raconter des
histoires
[Musique]
sera l'étincelle qui va lancer sa grande
fusée son grand succès le goût du
bonheur une saga historique de 2000
pages écrite en 9 mois Gabriel Adélaïde
et Florent figurent parmi les trois
livres francophones les plus vendus un
million d'exemplaires Marie labere est
arrivée ensuite j'allais dire le miracle
mais ce grand grand succès de votre
trilogie 2000 pages
vous êtes devenu vous êtes ici au niveau
des écrivains populaires dans le sens le
plus noble oui c'est bon et qu'est-ce
que est-ce que aujourd'hui le regard que
vous portez là dessus parce que je vous
ai élu vous avez essayé de la chance ce
n'est pas que de la chance
non c'est un amalgame je pense que
d'abord ce qui m'a fait écrire la
trilogie c'était un sentiment de dépit
c'est bizarre à dire mais après le
référendum après le préambule que
j'avais écrit puis après même la
réception journalistique qui avait été
extrêmement dur pour moi parce qu'on ne
croyait pas que je pouvais l'avoir fait
juste par conviction intime et ce pour
moi comme croit pas c'est comme quelque
chose comme attends c'est pas possible
il faut qu'on croit ah c'est fatiguant
oui c'est fatiguant alors après très
député je me suis dit Marie la politique
exploitache c'est pas ça
toi et aboie ta forêt comme tu peux puis
je me suis mis qu'est-ce que je voudrais
faire mais je voudrais donner aux gens
du Québec la fierté d'être ce qu'ils
sont
la sensation qu'on arrête de se
considérer comme des gens à peu près
corrects à peu près indépendant à peu
près comme toujours en voie de devenir
là ça me faisait vous êtes quelqu'un on
est déjà alors je me suis étudié
l'histoire puis tout ça pour essayer de
voir dans quelle creuset du 20e siècle
je mettrai j'ai pris donc le ventre
c'est à dire de 1930 à 70 qui précède
finalement les grands mouvements du
féminisme depuis de l'indépendance mais
pour moi c'était parler de ceux qui sont
là et qui ont fait notre société qui ont
fait notre révolte notre sentiment aussi
de dire non ça suffit on veut plus ça
comme ça on veut autrement
et puis la même mise de l'église qui a
commencé à disparaître après la Grande
Dépression parce que un moment donné
c'est bien beau la du milieu mais ça
c'est l'humidité l'humiliation c'est pas
même à faire je pense qu'on ne
comprennent différence dans le glaçage
si on est invité autour d'une table au
Québec les écrivains qui vivent bien de
cet art là il y aurait combien de monde
Marie Laberge
pour plus 6 pieds encore puis encore ça
baisse ça baisse l'achat de livre
certainement oui
six de même vite là mais c'est difficile
de vivre de sa plume je dirais que il
faut avoir un sens de comptabilité rare
ça me faisait toujours rire quand on
disait que c'était des poètes donc c'est
des esprits un peu en l'air quand on est
payé une seule fois par année et très
peu il faut quand même avoir un sens du
budget pour arriver puis pour vivre
correctement mais votre trilogie a
changé ça pour vous ça vous a donné la
liberté
la profonde liberté la plus grande
liberté oui absolument et c'est surtout
le lectorat que ça m'a apporté parce
qu'en France aussi puis en Suisse aussi
il y a eu des gens qui ont lu la
trilogie et ça se voit encore elle est
en pocket et puis c'est drôle parce que
je parlais avec les gens du Pocket puis
il me disait vous avez il y en a pas il
y en a pas 5 écrivain qui après 20 ans
vende encore autant dans un récent
sondage de la firme Léger où on
demandait au Québec de nommer les trois
meilleurs romans québécois Marie Laberge
arrive au cinquième rang avec Gabriel
après Les filles de Caleb d'Arlette
costume Bonheur d'occasion de Gabriel
Roy un homme et son péché de Claude
Henri Grignon et 51-50 rue des Ormes de
Patrick Senecal
si Marie Laberge a pu être regardé de
haut par les littéraires elle est fière
de faire partie des auteurs les plus lus
[Musique]
et en même temps ce grand succès là aux
yeux des gens dans le domaine de la
littérature c'est suspect là
et vous aimez Camus oui il vous dit à
cette citation de Camus qui écrit va
obscurement ont bien de la chambre ils
auront des commentateurs les autres
n'auront que des lecteurs ce qui
paraît-il et méprisable donc ça ça vous
rejoint ça oui ça ça clarté de parler au
monde au peuple les gens vous
comprennent c'est qu'ils apprennent
quelque chose ou bien qui soit même
reconnu à travers pour moi c'est la plus
grande chance au monde c'est à dire
d'atteindre quelqu'un de de j'ai pas moi
de soulever quelque chose qui qui
grondait dans cette personne là quelque
chose qui était pas nommé nommé quelque
chose combien de fois les gens m'ont dit
vous avez nommé ma peine
parce que vous m'avez donné des mots
pour comprendre ce qui m'habitait c'est
tout ce qui m'intéresse le reste que qui
a des thèses l'Universités faites sur
mon œuvre ils font cacherait morte ils
veulent pas le faire maintenant je sais
pas pourquoi c'est comme ça
il y a eu des thèses universités quand
même sur les saguais historiques et
Madame Desbiens verset de Laval de
devait connaître a dit c'est le
triptyque féminin c'est une hauteur une
écrivaine qui crée une héroïne lue par
des femmes
parce que beaucoup de vos lecteurs sont
des lectrices en fait beaucoup des
lecteurs sont d'électrices moins il y a
peut-être cette femme lectrice pour pour
trois ans je sais pas exactement mais
c'est sûr que en partant c'est sûr mais
moi je connais bien des hommes qui ont
lu mes livres et qui se sont pas trouvés
rejetés ou éloignés ou non concernant
oui j'avais raison parce que pour moi
j'écris pas en pensant à des gens ou
j'ai pas de public cible dans ma tête
jamais jamais pour moi l'humanité
comporte des hommes et des femmes et
c'est vraiment important que ça reste de
même parce que parce que c'est le monde
dans lequel moi je veux vivre Marie
Laberge
vous dites c'est bien d'être lu ça m'a
fait aussi penser aux poèmes de Kipling
qui dit tu peux rester noble en étant
populaire et je trouvais que ça vous
allait bien tu peux rester pas en
conseillant les rois tu peux de pas
s'éloigner de la société du peuple où on
vit façon pour qui on peut se prendre on
veut tous mourir pour qui on peut se
prendre pour un roi pour quelqu'un je me
suis pas une grande pensée ou je suis un
être humain mais je suis humaine
profondément et c'est bien correct pour
moi et j'étais étonné je disais vous
écrivez aussi
ardu c'est un exercice vous vous isolez
vous alliez dans le main au bord de la
mer je crois encore ah oui donc le
premier jet est-ce que vous aimez écrire
oui le premier mot c'est oui le deuxième
c'est ouais sauf qu'une fois rendu des
fois j'aille ça il y a des matins
mais je dirais que il y a dans moi
un élan le plus grand d'énergie que j'ai
c'est pour écrire c'est la puis pourtant
j'en ai pour bien des affaires mais
quand je me mets à écrire c'est comme là
je sais que je suis à ma place je sais
que je suis c'est parfait c'est là
continue même quand ça marche pas même
quand je suis littéralement en détresse
en me disant oh mon dieu non ça pourrait
pas ça peut pas je me suis un trilogie
il y a eu des moments je me suis dit non
non je fais de garde là demain tu te
lèves et puis tu recommences c'est tout
puis si ça fait peau poubelle ça se
passe en toi ma poubelle il y a personne
qui attend ta page là je recommenceras
mais c'est un gros travail c'est énorme
et ça prend une énergie puis une
constance ça prend une concentration
mais en même temps
c'est tellement riche j'ai l'impression
que je descends dans des sous-sols pas
de lumière et là je vais à la rencontre
des émotions que j'ignore et que je
contiens puis vous laissez guider
absolument je descends quand je commence
je suis très bien le propos le sujet que
je vais aborder mais je sais pas comment
il va se révéler vous avez parlé de
cette déclaration se préambule que vous
avez écrit il y a de cela quelques
années pensant que le Québec allait dire
oui que les Québécois le dire ouais la
souveraineté le monsieur Parisot vous
avez demandé entre autres à vous et ado
d'écrire un préambule vous en êtes où
face à ce projet d'indépendance du
Québec les années ont passé disons et
les Québécois ont dit non deux fois
je sais pas où j'en suis je trouve que
on reste on reste des gens bien
particuliers je me sens jamais
canadienne jamais quand les gens disent
vous êtes Canadiens les mêmes quand j'y
vais j'aime le Canada j'aime bien ce
pays là je le visite à l'occasion mais
je me sens pas faisant partie d'une
communauté
anglophone même artistiquement on a de
la misère à faire des échanges les
traductions sont difficiles j'arrive pas
à le traduire en anglais au Canada
pourtant ça coûte rien à un éditeur le
Conseil des arpèges non il y a comme des
barrières qui sont toujours là peut-être
pour moi peut-être pas pour les autres
j'en sais rien mais on est un peuple on
est un peuple particulier
particulièrement résilient
particulièrement fort et
particulièrement
je dirais aimable dans le sens digne
d'être aimé il nous aime moi moi je nous
aime
mais on a quand même collectivement les
Québécois ont dit on ne veut pas quand
même aller au bout de ce rêve là mais
l'essentiel reste là c'est ce que vous
dites là
voyons donc on reste qui on est s'il
fallait s'habiller parce qu'on a dit
qu'une idée qu'est-ce qu'on fait mais
avez-vous abdiqué ou ça va arriver dans
votre esprit moi j'ai fait ce que je
pouvais moi j'ai fait ce que je pouvais
et comme j'ai dit ma hache c'est
d'écrire d'écrire sur ceux qui sont ici
avec leur l'acheter avec leur force leur
courage votre dernier roman avant de
parler d'avenir Marie-Laure je veux je
veux vous parler de celui-là parce que
moi mon travail c'est de faire des
nouvelles et je décris malheureusement
des tragédies il y a eu à l'aval
récemment il y a eu il y en a plein
malheureusement
et ce qui est fascinant dans ce livre là
c'est que vous puis je veux savoir
pourquoi ça vous intéressait à ce point
vous vous demandez que deviennent les
gens autour
et ça prend je prends deux cent pages
avant qu'on entend même le tueur qui est
presque accessoire exact
ça vous vient d'où c'est vraiment que
deviennent ces gens autour après le jour
d'après la semaine d'après 18 mois après
oui parce que c'est ça moi qui
m'intéresse c'est pas la nouvelle ce que
vous faites vous vous exposez quelque
chose et après moi je me dis oui le
matin
où est-ce qu'elle est la souffrance qui
a fait de ça où est-ce que c'est comment
quelqu'un va sur l'idée de ça m'est
venue au 20e anniversaire des tours de
New York
ils ont mis le décompte des morts et je
me suis dit après 20 ans combien
d'autres sont morts de ces morts combien
de gens se sont tués combien de gens ont
développé des cancers à combien de gens
toutes sortes de morts qui sont liées à
cette perte-là soit parce que la
déchirure a été trop grande et que le
cœur a pas tenu soit parce que parce que
l'envie de vivre pour voulu résister je
sais pas eux m'intéressent énormément
les silencieux les muets les ignorer les
délaissés les mépriser tout cela il
m'intéresse toutes les êtres humains qui
ont pas de voix c'est moi qui pourrait
peut-être leur donner un écho mais là le
point de rupture dans la vie là tout à
coup on casse et on se dit je pourrais
pas mais on peut on peut on pense qu'on
peut pas puis on peut puis ça nous fait
chier qu'on puisse on veut pas pouvoir
quand quelqu'un meurt on veut pas
pouvoir s'en remettre on veut que ce
soit toujours sortir reste mais c'est
pas vrai et on devient pas tout à coup
un héros au milieu de sa vie c'est
vraiment le courage ça s'apprend marche
après marche Maria pour que la chaîne
soit solide on peut pas apprendre le
courage d'un coup parce qu'il nous est
arrivé un drame mais il y a des solides
qu'il faut savoir accepter à partir du
moment où on le sait on est 1000 fois
plus fort plus solide plus capable de
rire et l'avenir Marie Laberge parlant
de plus solide capable de rire est-ce
que vous est-ce que vous faites
qu'est-ce qui masserve dans votre pas
mal d'affaires
maintenant je reviens de mon exil donc
j'ai un manuscrit et probablement que
mon avenir ça va être de mettre ce livre
je l'ai donné à mes trois premières
lectrices qui sont les mêmes depuis plus
de 35 40 ans ah oui
j'attendais la peine non non je l'ai eu
ça serait pas chez mon éditrice si je
l'avais pas eu mes trois premières
lectrices
c'est quelque chose d'unique dans ma vie
c'est quelque chose que j'ai jamais fait
et quelque chose que je ne voulais pas
faire ça je peux vous dire ça donc il y
a comme une victoire dans moi de l'avoir
fait mais il y a une grande découverte
de moi à travers ça de ma capacité
d'écrire autrement je dirais autrement
ou c'est que
ça sera disponible
l'automne je
prévois pour l'automne donc 16e roman
puis là il y en aura d'autres vous
écrivez jusqu'à temps que vous puissiez
obtenir le crayon probablement j'aurai
une plume dans les mains j'espère je
sais pas mais c'est sûr que c'est ma
meilleure façon de vivre moi pour bien
vivre bien respirer à être bien je dois
écrire c'est sûr c'est ma manière à moi
c'est la Bible que je suis j'étais une
actrice j'étais toute seule d'affaires
mais rien à cote le sentiment de
presque de liberté totale et d'être à
150% ce que je suis en terminant Marie
Laberge les vertus
qui vous plaisent le plus dans la vie
les qualités chez les gens les vertus
que vous élevez le plus je dirais le
courage le courage ça c'est certainement
la plus belle des vertus extraordinaire
c'est ce que j'avais écrit chasseur
j'ai mis courage on avait bien compris
ça c'est sûr que vous avez compris
toutes les épreuves que vous décrivez
dans vos livres
ça prend du courage aussi pour les
affronter ou les décrire ou pour aller
au fond de la nature humaine dans ce
cas-là de moins noble et de plus noble
les deux en même temps souvent les deux
sont très très voisins mais certainement
le courage oui la franchise l'honnêteté
l'intégrité ça c'est quelque chose que
je mettrai haut dans mon échelle à moi
ça et puis l'humanité
je trouve qu'il faut il faut renouveler
un peu ce moule je pense qu'il faut
ouvrir un petit peu plus on a le
sarcasme bien bien proche des lèvres on
a on a des violences verbales maintenant
qui sont tout à coup qui était
inadmissibles il y a 50 ans Marie
Laberge on a de lire 10 jours donc
quelque part à l'automne merci beaucoup
de nous avoir ça me fait presque pas
j'espère que ça vous fait peur vous là
dedans Marie Laberge merci beaucoup
merci merci